gonna try and do this as a short but
there's a lot to cover YouTube is
messing with monetization again creators
Got a notification they come November uh
our ability to control some of the
settings on monetization is being taken
away particularly in terms of pre and uh
post roles the as they come before or at
the end of a video they are removing our
ability to set them on or off they're
going to make that decision they're
basically now going to be permanently on
but an algorithm is going to decide
whether it is appropriate to play the ad
or not based off other viewing habits
and other optimization stuff that we
will never know we are not going to even
know how many of the ads that are on
there are even playing which means we
are losing visibility on data which is
going to make it easier to withhold
funds from us if they ever decide to do
that and we would have almost no way to
prove it officially they're not messing
with mid-rolls yet although they kind of
are I did a video on that before but
that's unofficial I would not be
surprised if within five years they take
away our ability to set our own
mid-rolls as well all of it seems to be
moving towards their total control of
the monetization they are already
introducing the tools that could easily
become mandatory later